thank you
good morning from the European
Parliament here in Strasbourg and thank
you for joining this live stream
uh I'm Robert hucci from the social
media team tomorrow marks the
international day uh for the elimination
against uh violence against women
um and today actually we want to focus
on an important topic that's going on in
Iran on the right fundamental rights of
women in Iran and their fights
for this cause I'm joined by two members
of the parliament so Swedish members of
the parliament who have been very vocal
uh on this topic abir al-salani from the
centuries group in new Europe and
they've been in Syria on my right from
the Socialists and Democrats thank you
very much for joining thank you for
having us
um
the protest that erupted uh almost uh
two months ago more than two months ago
in Iran uh
um were as a result of the death of
masamini a 22 year old detained by the
country's morality police after she was
arrested for supposedly not wearing her
veil properly we want to talk today
about this uh the situation that's going
on in Iran and we also have another
guest joining us from Skype from abroad
uh or an Iranian human rights activist
who actually whose identity we cannot
disclose for security reasons uh in the
second part of this interview we will
have our on and if you want to ask your
questions and send us your comments and
be part of these discussions you can do
so by putting it in the comment section
I'm reminding you that we are live on
Facebook and on YouTube
um evidence here you have been uh you
had a prominent role in adopting uh the
European parliament's October resolution
on the death of Masa amini further to
parliament's request the EU has proposed
as adopted sanctions against the
individuals and institutions involved in
the masamine's death and the violent
Crackdown on protesters could you
comment what is happening right now on
Iran and what prompted you and your
colleagues to adopt such a strong
resolution
first and foremost thank you for
initiating this very important
discussion because the women and girls
in Iran are still facing tremendous
tremendous oppression day by day it's
getting heavier and heavier and if
looking at the 40 over 40 years of
Oppression that women and girls have
been facing including minorities and
other groups in Iran and how the
demonstrations evolved it was our I felt
together with colleagues that is our
duty as the European Parliament as
elected officials to act it's good with
manifestations but the actions are those
things that need that leads to change
and therefore we also initiated the
resolution in the Parliament that
demanded strong sanctions but yet we
haven't seen strong enough sanctions and
strong and enough actions I would say in
from the side of the European Union
um I'll be outside Han you have recently
uh been in uh the world's media
attention for a very symbolic gesture
here in the parliament expressing
solidarity with the Iranian women by
cutting your hair in the chamber why did
you do this gesture and what did what
did it mean to you at the time and what
did you want your message to who did you
want your message to be heard by thank
you for having us and welcome to all the
viewers welcome to the parliament well
to be honest I think I'm not alone when
I say that there is a frustration that
is growing by the day because of the
absence of Global Leadership that is
clear on the fight for human rights for
what is decent for what is right for
democracy for rule of law the
International Community is actually
lacking behind and its passiveness when
it comes to the fight of uh four human
rights for democracy for Freedom that
absence is creating this frustration and
two weeks after the killing of Masa
amini the general assembly of the UN
gathered in New York and only one of the
global leaders there dared to mention
Iran but didn't mention massa's killings
so I mean there there has been a
frustration that was that was growing by
the day by this uh total absence of uh
referral to to what was going on in Iran
at that time and still going on and then
I was sitting in the in plenary and the
high representative for foreign affairs
Mr Joseph Burrell was just mumbling out
a press release that you know with the
speaking points and I couldn't take it
anymore I was so Furious because
if there is something that we can do if
there is something that we can support
when it comes to women taking to the
street shouting on the top of their
lungs calling for freedom and basic
human rights with the highest price that
they're paying their lives and we just
Mumble press releases it's not good
enough for the only Union of democracies
in the world
so that's why I needed to to show these
women in Iran that their voices were
heard that their demands for basic human
rights were echoed In This Very chamber
uh evidence you have been involved also
in legislative work of the parliament
for eliminating violence against women
can you tell us more about this work and
what does it how important is it for you
as a member of the European Parliament
to not only promote uh the fundamental
rights of women here in Europe but also
outside of it it's a co-operator
together with another colleague on the
European Union's um first ever holistic
legislation on combating gender-based
violence within the European Union but
if for centuries of the centuries for
decades of of the Decades year after
year women in the European Union women
beyond our borders have and are facing
oppression we are facing oppression
during peace times we are facing
oppression during war times
and the gender-based violence that
exists in all Societies in all countries
all across the world needs to come to an
end and as a woman myself and as a young
girl also previously I saw very well how
there was difference between when going
up between boys and girls and today I
see the big differences between women
and men women are in practice
second-class citizens within the
European Union even because we are being
treated as if our voices doesn't matter
there is a lack of representation there
is huge violence against women in our
societies and we see also in oppressing
regimes for example in Iran how one of
the first things dictator and oppressors
does is to Target women and girls we
also see it in the case of Ukraine for
example how the Russian uh how the
Russian military soldiers use sexual
violence as um as oppressing tool
against women and girls the same we have
also got to know is used by the Iranian
regime so oppression in against women
and girls have been used all all across
history and in all societies and it
needs to end
and now we're going to connect to a
human rights activist who is joining us
via Skype from abroad and whose identity
we cannot disclose I don't know if you
hear me
yes very bad thank you thank you for
joining thank you for joining this live
chat I will have a few questions for you
uh so what is it uh I hope you are safe
right now uh where you are connecting uh
to us from what is it like to be a human
rights activist in Iran and how is the
situation of uh other human rights
activists right now in the country
at first I just uh want to really
appreciate and thank these two amazing
ladies for the things that they were
just saying right now because it's
absolute the true and the things that is
happening inside the Iran
um the situation is that for us human
rights activists the situation was
always really bad we were persecuted we
were under heavy threats and many times
during many Uprising that happened past
40 years
part of our civil society had to leave
the country and go on anxiety this time
the situation was like the country was
sort of exploding but in one good side
the all these works of especially women
right activists
cause a sort of awareness among the
young people that they like I'm so proud
of this Uprising and if let's say call
it Revolution that the slogan is woman
life freedom because
it's it's getting paid off like all
those difficult years that for simple
rights you have to go to long-term
prison or you have to left your family
be a refugee
for us for me personally like because
my colleagues they got arrested we
temporarily had to uh leave the country
just to be safe not get persecuted and
don't know you know what's gonna happen
to us but we are basically displaced we
cannot go back and this is such a you
know big burden for the many
activists that they are sort of outside
of the country they are still so much
connected with the ground and they just
want to raise the voice of Iranian
people and Iranian women that we are in
such emergency situation that you know
today it's even late
every second every minute people are
under torture people are getting killed
so I really like the the one of your MPS
they were saying that like we need
action just right now it is really
important how are you helping other
women from outside the country where you
are now people who are still in the
country and still fighting in the
streets of Iran
or can you even how is how difficult is
it or how easy it is how can you how are
you right now
um supporting them
I want to know about your challenges
for my specific case one of the main
case that I was working it was through
women's right in a sport so now with
this uh like whole Qatar World Cup it's
a really you know good time to again
raise awareness about the massive human
rights violation going on the other part
for many of us is that since we were
inside the Iran and because of all the
problem we couldn't really
um you know these girls our Identity or
with our own name we talk to other you
know colleagues outside
your source of disconnected one of the
things that these days we are doing a
lot is that to get United together
because
let's say women write and view a
violation against women all around the
world sort of is the same like we are
fighting one cause which is the women's
right and our dignity we are all really
United and we should be United more
thank you finally what is your message
to not only to the two members of the
parliament I have here who have been
fighting to promote uh or to to be the
voice of the of the women of Iran here
in the parliament but also to other EU
leaders
I am so confident at least these two
brilliant ladies they're gonna bring our
voice to there because you're just share
your words you cannot imagine like how
many people even cried when you cut your
hair when we hear your voice this is
like Beyond because it's been so many
years that we are trying to say like we
are doing here please help us support us
but unfortunately politicians prefer let
me say Sixth Gen their male politicians
prefer to shake hands together and we
will always get silent and they said
like it is your culture you should
respect your this is not our culture
women right it's not it's a red line we
don't let you you know pass this and we
will raise our voices
um I just want them everyone know that
we are in a such it like remember as SOS
we are in that situation and we need
immediate you know help to just not more
people getting killed the amount of
people in these two months got killed it
is more than many recent Wars that
happened in uh you know origin or in
general so we have to be really careful
because when you lose a generation it
happens to a 2009 it happened to us 2019
it happened to us then we like that much
go down to the sorrow and like a
darkness that we cannot go out really
please just help us
thank you and thank you for joining us
and please stay safe now I'll have uh my
guest uh here in the studio comment on
on your message
thank you thank you
I want to have your comments first uh
well I mean um what are we just doing
there are a couple of things that I
would like to mention one of them is
that I know that maybe the regime won't
change tomorrow
but I know that Iran is not going back
to the day prior to the killings of Masa
amini Iran has changed fundamentally
forever
and it is thanks to the fight the
revolution of these women
and when these women in Iran these Brave
courageous women in Iran took the to the
streets shouting for their freedom for
basic human rights for rule of law for
democracy
what they did is Showcase the lack of
Global Leadership on one hand but also
how we have been neglecting the fight of
women because whenever men take to the
street and Fight For Freedom then it's
totally different thing but when women
do that we do not acknowledge it in the
same way and that is so fundamentally
wrong
my third point that I want to to make is
it is like if the International
Community is just waiting for this
revolution to self-die we are not
betting that they are going to win and
that makes me Furious that makes me
crazy Furious why are we not supporting
them enough so they can win this this
revolution so they because people in
Iran deserve basic human rights they
deserve democracy they deserve freedom I
mean why aren't we acting more I'm happy
that the foreign ministers came to a
decision to introduce that package of
sanctions that's very good but now we
need to act even more Resolute now we
need also to show support for the inside
I mean yes two days ago I was on Twitter
space with the liberal Think Tank and
people were saying that the injured
protesters do not dare to go to the
hospitals because then they take them to
the police so they are in that higher
need of medical supplies because there
are doctors who are good enough who are
human enough to to support them with
medical assistance but that then they
don't have any supplies so we need to
find these channels to so we can
actively support the protesters and we
really need to have a solution for for
the internet blockage so the people
there the protesters the activists can
coordinate their actions because one of
the things that I have been hearing is
that you know it's not a coordinated
thing that is going on in Iran well they
are not allowed to be coordinated
because the the the regime has blocked
the internet
and one last remark is that this
revolution has to be inclusive and we
have to address also the the thing I
mean the issues of lgbti community we
have to talk about the Kurds that have
been I mean massacred now in mahabat we
have to talk also about the minorities
and you cannot have a fight of course we
stay United but having an inclusive
fight and an inclusive narrative will
create a better democracy ahead
uh evidence here first I want you to
comment on what are the human rights
Defender guest uh just said but also uh
what are you expecting you called it uh
you both called it a feminist
revolutionary why is it different this
time
the um
a message from the human rights Defender
was of course very emotional and it also
uh really once again highlighted the
importance of actions by the
International Community but I would also
say that it the lack of action is as
simple as this that if we look at who
are the heads of States who are the
decision makers in general
um because me and avir are not the main
rule unfortunately the most of them are
men
uh in in a power position
lacking the perspective of the
oppression that women and girls are
facing today have been facing all
through the history and and the same
goes all across the world
and that I would say is one of the
biggest reasons of why there is a lack
of actions
and when it comes to the situation in
the country
yes it is a feminist Revolution because
it's a woman and girl-led even girls say
in the age of six seven eight is taking
on the streets really sharing showing
the courage that many of us here in this
Parliament do not dare to show
and shouting women life freedom I also
want to remind of the slogan of a woman
life Freedom where it comes from it
comes from from there were a Kurdish
slogan
Azadi it actually started in the area
where I was myself grown up in the
northern part of Kurdistan or
Southeastern turkey and it wonder it
walked to the Syrian parts
where the pyd ypg ypj Kurdish forces
fought against Isis under the slogan of
zhenjian Azadi and it walked over to the
Iranian pouch also in the Kurdish party
and then whole Iran and now we are
hearing everybody shouted all across the
world so I totally agree with abir also
that is that mentioned the issue of
democracy that the um the gender the
fight for gender equality needs to also
be inclusive and it also needs to
Encompass the fight for lgbtqi rights
the minorities and so on and so forth
the feminist Revolution is a part of a
long ongoing Democratic revolution in
the country that need our support
thank you
um what impact are you expecting on
these sanctions by the EU
because the death makers or the
so-called lawmakers in Iran just urged
the government to execute all the
detained protesters and I do hope that
we impose sanctions on these debt makers
and their families because we know that
many of the people in in the regime of
the mullahs are are having their
families outside and their assets
outside of Iran and that cannot continue
we have to starve the regime in Iran
this is this is what we need to do so
the impact of the sanctions I do hope
it's starvation of the of the money and
we know also that the Revolutionary God
is the institution in Iran that is
controlling the money it is controlling
their businesses and I was so happy when
the bazaar the souk in in Tehran
closed in as a protest and that is the
old money that was talking you know in
Iran that we are not anymore accepting
this and I think that was a very
courageous but also very necessary and
important Showcase of solidarity with
the ongoing feminist Revolution so uh
what the thing one of the issues that
that we also need to highlight is the
need of of support for the political
opposition
because I do believe that Iran will
change politically and then you need a
party political system that is ready so
they can you know take over and I I hope
that we can
not only starve the mulas regime not
only
have targeted sanctions towards the
Revolutionary guard and the morality
police and all these men but also try to
create a safe haven a safe arena for the
political opposition to form itself so
they can eventually not only mobilize
but in the prolonging also take over
I mean do you do you believe that this
Parliament and the EU institutions and
new governments can help not only the
political opposition but uh Drive uh
progress in Iran I mean the progress is
already coming from inside but we need
to show the support the international
need to show the support including the
European Union uh we cannot as we have
been done until now beyond the side of
the moonlas which is evident the
International Community until now have
been because they haven't targeted
sanctioned them enough they haven't been
hard enough against them they haven't
demand what should be uh be not a dream
but a reality in Iran democracy and
human rights gender equality is uh is
human rights women and girls rights are
a matter of Human Rights so I think that
we have a big responsibility in the
support of the freedom fighters on the
streets of all around Iran to end this
oppression
uh we have seen also women protesting in
Europe uh for the for the rights of uh
Iranian women and and it's been very
encouraging do you think how do you
think women in The Wider region uh
around Iran uh are seeing this what's
going on there
uh
just to make a quick remark that you
know I know that many Europeans our
citizens have their roots in Iran
Iranian Europeans are a big diaspora and
these Europeans our citizens our voters
have not been able to function properly
because they have been worried sick
about relatives about friends family
colleagues former you know students
University colleagues and all of that
and I know that many of them are day and
night following the news they're
reporting calling trying to get hold of
people and
our I mean for me a lot of what I'm
doing is also about these people who are
here because they are really really
worried about the situation and they're
very much involved in in the situation
uh what was your question my question
was about uh about how uh women in the
region in the wider Regency uh what's
going on uh I do hope that they get
inspired uh one worrying aspect has been
um
the uh
the perception that we are attacking a
religion
no we are not we are attacking a
political system and this has to be very
clear above all maybe to the Arab
speaking countries
that we are not attacking any religion I
myself Define myself as a Muslim woman
but I am what I am protesting against is
a political system that is based on
oppressing women and treating them as a
second-class Citizens not giving them
equal rights not giving them basic human
rights and if there is anything that you
should be supporting in your life is
actually the fight for equality the
fight for human rights that's basically
it and I hope that we don't forget the
uh the situation also in Afghanistan and
the imposed gender apartheid by the
talibans because these women are are
also in dire need of support where they
have been erased from the face of their
country from the face of Earth treated
like air treated like nothing so I hope
that we can managed to keep up the fight
and keep up the support for all these
women around this area
because they really deserve human rights
they deserve to live in democracies and
they deserve to live in Freedom and it
is their demand
do you think women in the region can
find Hope in what is going on in Iran
today
we not only think that they can find out
they find Hope in what is happening
right now in Iran women all across the
Middle East I mean just look at also the
revolution for
2010-2011 in Middle East and North
Africa where women actually were in the
front of the Revolution however when
Revolution ended it was the man that
took the power so we need to continue
supporting these women
all across Middle East North Africa and
also globally
so I am very sure and I see every day
how they find courage in each other and
I also want to highlight the the issue
of of the Afghan women because the same
oppression that women are facing in Iran
they have the women and girls are facing
also in Afghanistan since 15th of August
to 2021 when the Taliban stole the power
because exactly the same thing as the
mulas in branded 1979 the talibans did
15th of August 2021
therefore also I actually initiated the
resolution here in this Parliament that
was um that is going to be adopted in
one hour hopefully and we had the debate
on the situation in Afghanistan
yesterday because it is very evident
that what is happening in Afghanistan is
also a gender apartheid definitely
deteriorating human rights situation in
Iran is also on the table of the Human
Rights Council U.N Human Rights Council
what actions can we expect from The
Wider community
um on the situation in Iran
I mean for for one maybe for one maybe
kicking out Iran from the U.N women uh
uh for one we can start there uh
but now really uh we we really need to
start the regime
that that's basically it cut off the
money everything that will create income
for the regime and it's men we need to
just cut it off this is what we need to
do as an International Community and
then also support the protesters so they
can organize mobilize and eventually
take over
uh as I mentioned in the beginning of
this uh live chat tomorrow is the U.N
International Day on the elimination of
violence against women
uh I want a short message from both of
you uh on the situation of women about
uh of human rights in Europe and
especially the particularly of women and
their fight for their fundamental rights
and uh and uh yeah for the situation of
women uh wherever they are in the world
and especially in vulnerable regions
like Iran and Middle East
well women's rights are human rights and
it's not a question of if or or it is a
question of to ensure then ensure those
rights and I as a woman will never beg
anyone to uh to understand the situation
but I will demand that those rights that
we have the right to that are
constituted in the U.N Charter that is
in the basic values of the European
Union are respected in Europe and all
across the world then and um
I
I of course stand in solidarity with
with the women and girls all across the
world because we have the same struggle
wherever Patrick wherever oppression
shows its face
last word to you I have a very basic
message to say woman life freedom
thank you very much for being here uh
and uh thank you to the human rights
activists who joined us from abroad and
thank you to everyone who has joined
this live chat uh I hope to see you soon
in our future live chats
thank you